all right patience
patience where'd you grow up where are
you from originally alaska you grew up
in alaska
really 10 years
10 years in alaska and uh and then
where'd you move after that
um la silla alaska fairbanks alaska and
then california
you moved to california
how long have you been in california a
year how old are you now 11. you're 11.
and a half and now you're on skid row
what do you think of skid row
it's kind of fun um mommy has a lot of
friends one of the names is friends um
of hers isn't it i'm watching her turtle
this is her it's a girl
mine's a boy
tell me what uh
your mom's life on skid row is like
um
what's the question
so you're staying with your mom yeah and
what what what is your mom's life like
here on skid row
well she watched tv with me a lot on
your phone
you watched you watch your shows on the
phone yeah
and you're living in a tent yeah
what's it like living in a town
very
hot
yeah it's hot this time of year isn't it
yeah mom sweats a lot it gets cold in
the middle in the wintertime
not really
not alaska cold but it's cold
kinda
then your mom got
somebody beat up your mom last night i
heard huh did your mom get beaten up
yesterday
no
oh somebody told me i thought your mom
told me she got beaten up no this
morning your mom got beaten up this
morning
what happened
um well uh her boyfriend said that um
she took his five dollars but she gave
her
she she gave him his money back
yesterday
and then he took her phone
what's it like when you're watching your
mom get beaten up
kai scary i would think
it's a horrible thing to watch yeah but
my sister and grandma i grew up with
that my sister and grandma would always
fight
so you saw a lot of people getting
beaten up
in your family
especially when we let
this family stay with us in our house a
few years ago
like six five or six years ago and we
became friends um the girl was
madison the boy was mason they were
twins
and they would they're staying with us
for like almost a year
and then when they left they decided to
take all the good food
and then so my grandma didn't like that
so she um started to yell at them and
then the um they started being her up so
my older sister came out and um beat her
up and then after that um
um they left but they lived across on
the road i'm like not on the road but
they lived in an igloo house
this is in alaska of course
patience uh
where's your dad
um
uh somewhere in alaska
was he in your life at all
yeah but he never really came around
you're raised by your mom and your my
grandma and my great grandma
do you have any friends down here let's
get wrong no
not my i'm not no
no i i haven't made any friends
yeah
i only have one best friend his name is
connor i haven't seen him in like three
years
hey are you going to school
yeah but not yet it's not time it's
summertime right yeah what grade are you
in
i'm going in sixth grade sixth grade do
you like school
um
kinda i like the math
did you guys
do you eat well when you're down here in
skid row
yeah sometimes i have scallop noodles
and then sometimes we order pizza and
then most of the time i love mcdonald's
so we get mcdonald's
yeah
but on mondays we order door dash or
uber
and they bring it to your tent
no they bring it to night in san pedro
you pick up your food and bring it to
wherever
yeah we live on nights in san juan so
it's not that far it's just like a block
away
what do you think of all the people down
here on skid row
oh very nice there's one person named d
um he's nice and he loves these turtles
and then across from us there's q
and a those are mom's friends
and then
that's mostly the people i know
and then at the market the omar works
and the trees works the big guy's not
very friendly
what do you think everyone why is
everyone down here on skid row
um because they did something bad
and some of them are young don't want to
get a job
but
um that might be because they went to
jail or something
yeah
a lot a lot of people down here are
doing drugs too
that kind of keeps people from getting a
job and keeps them from
doing anything with their life yeah
you think there's any chance that one
day you might do drugs
oh no
um but my older brother dies and shows
my older sister and i'm pretty sure my
younger brother will too
but i don't think i will
what about your your family your mom and
your grandmother and all that
my great-grandma doesn't do drugs
my grandma i um she passed away i'm a
year ago but i don't know if she did and
then my mom i don't know either yeah
what would you like to do when you grow
up you have any ideas
maybe be a lot of
special victims person i like that one i
like the tv show
have you ever watched law and order i
have not
oh it's on ion
my great grandma doesn't let me watch it
very um a lot
what do you think of california compared
to alaska
it's a little too hot here
yeah alaska is a lot chillier right
and you're seeing the very worst part of
california too right
this is scooter was pretty bad yeah
when i get older well hopefully before i
get older i want to buy it back on my
grandma's old house
do you think your friends back in alaska
would even believe what's going on down
here
no
maybe my best friend connor because he
went through the same thing oh he did
but not here in alaska
um after that um
his mom passed away
when i was six
and he was probably about nine
and then after that i hadn't seen him
for like
four three more years
and then after that
i saw him again
and then after that
that was the last time
i was nine
what was the best time of your life
what's your best memory your favorite
memory of your life in your life
[Music]
probably going to the gravel pit
it was right by our house we just went
down a little something and there was a
gravel pit it was huge we like to pick
rocks there
what do you do for fun here
watch tv
really anything to do here yeah
especially for a kid
have you been outside of skid row
yeah um for most of the year we lived at
the stuart hotel on seventh and union
i'm right by food for less and
lowe's or home depot or whatever it was
called and then the mcdonald's right
across from us and so is the starbucks
yeah but that's still kind of
not too far from skid row
it's a big california's a big state
there's a lot more to it
hopefully you'll get to see it one day
what do you do you think your mom is
going to keep you down here do you think
you guys will go somewhere
um well we've been talking to people
um
a lot of people are getting housing now
yeah the caseworker has come but she
wanted to um go to um uh send us to a
good shepherd
isn't it like a treatment place or
something could be yeah i think it is
and they don't have staff bedroom but
then the other lady came um when she was
rubbing sunburn on my sunburn you know
and the other leg came and then she said
that she has a friend
some healing something of something
and then after that she said
uh
he could get us he could look at a place
within 48 hours
but they haven't texted back yet
what do you wish for your family for you
and your mom
to have a house to have a house
i wish we could buy back my grandma's
old house but that's a lot of money
that would be back in alaska yeah would
you be happier in alaska you think
it would be closer to my friends
i know i could ask if i also like here
too
you what i'm sorry i like alaska but i
also like it here too what do you like
about california
um
[Music]
they're not coldness
yeah
well patients i hope you and your mom
figure out a way to get away from skid
row
that would be great
there's other places in california that
i think you guys could probably much
happier
are we done yet we're done
you're so cute
what are your turtles names
the boy's name is franklin michael
jackson
frank is just short and the girl's name
is fiona mary jane
thank you darla